eight-month-old son survived the long
journey by Road from Sudan
but now his health is deteriorating
[Music]
my child has diarrhea fever he's
coughing and his throat is swollen
at a Transit camp for refugees and
returnees in rank health workers soon
realized he's severely malnourished he
needs to go to the hospital
urgently
tens of thousands of people are fleeing
the conflict in Sudan some to
neighboring countries such as South
Sudan children are especially vulnerable
these people have
long distance from where the their
locations said their homes to here and
don't have food access to food
conditions diseases maybe somewhere ill
and yeah they are deteriorating with
time by the time they get here their
nutrition status is as deteriorated when
families cross the border many stay in
transit camps where conditions are rough
opened on the 26th of April it started
off small but now look at it it's grown
in size it's now full some people are
now sleeping on the street in churches
and in schools because there is no space
more people are still crossing the
border you'll also need somebody to stay
overcrowding could lead to diseases
Southern Kaka Angelou worries about she
left Sudan with her daughter and mother
her child is now in hospital severely
malnourished
she got sick when war in sudanes started
there was no time to go to the hospital
we just ran during the journey she
became worse seeing her daughter lose
weight so quickly frightened Kaka she
wonders of living Khartoum was the right
thing to do
haramutasa Al Jazeera rank South Sudan
Pakistan's anti-terrorism